what's up guys and crazy RGB trend in
the past few years has now even carried
on to rim coarser revealed there are GB
RAM sticks to the public just earlier
last year when they released this Ram
the price was only $150 for a 16
gigabyte kit which is in line with all
the other RAM sticks at the time however
as NAND flash has had a shortage in the
past couple of months rent prices have
skyrocketed now a thirty-two hundred
megahertz kit from coarser costs two
hundred and twenty-five dollars has that
fifty percent increase from its original
price however you can buy a non RGB ddr4
kit which is also thirty two hundred
megahertz from g.skill for 185 dollars
which is still quite overpriced but it
is four dollars cheaper and of course
your RGB kit as a result now there is a
quite tangible disparity between the non
RGB and RGB kits so that brings up the
question of its RGB really worked 40
dollars well today I'm going to be going
over the course area link software and a
different RGB effects up this ramp I
hope to answer that question at the end
of this video I'm also going to be going
over to XMP profiles so let's jump right
in
well guys here is the course your link
software this is what you guys use to be
able to control the LED effects of the
RGB Ram so on this there's many
different sections like you can see my
liquid cooler up there around here but
we want to go to the RAM section as he
is just be Ram right here so there's a
lot of different option that you guys
can choose first you have a group Curran
group I'm just gonna leave that group
just
listen state so promote first mode is
static and you gotta choose whatever
color you want red blue and it's just
okay and apply and then you can see
color off the RAM is now standing blue
next let's look at the next mode the
next mode is color we'll see
so for color pulse you guys can choose
as many colors as you want I'm just
gonna leave it at 6 right here and
there's all those colors you can change
each part individually you can go
through here maybe yellow if you wanna
make this one pain for boys you make it
each one any flaw you guys want and you
can also change the speed so right now
it's gonna leave the boot lid done and
what this does is that it leaves the two
bands it takes
right here as you can see make color
pulses together they both come on at the
same time and they go off at the same
time to let me put it it's full speed so
you guys can see it better
they both come on the same time and go
off at the same time Jeffrey's a good
light you can shoot a pet I said that
short and what that does is that it
lights up one Ram stick before the other
and the distance between the two
different illuminations is short so as
you can see it's like that and now with
that what you can do you can make it
forward or backwards right now it's back
first let me put it forward and as you
can see would go to the other direction
then you can change it to medium
or long
at this point it's like Ortiz moving on
to music
okay now let's go to the next move next
part is color shift and same thing you
guys have had to choose how many colors
you want and change to each color and
leave this speed at full and again
there's a group delay for this as well
and that's the same function let's apply
here as you can see it just changes to
all the colors you guys choose
after that next option is rainbow
and for this again speed and playing
this this looks pretty cool I think this
is actually one of my favorite ones and
finally if you guys really want to go
really in detail you could make it
ungrouped you guys can set each one
separately I'm not gonna go in jet
because it's exactly the same thing it's
just gonna be separate so guys that's it
for the course your link software at all
the RGB effects of the RAM so now as for
overclocking this ramp it's actually
very simple it comes with the exit B
profile and you just select down into
BIOS and you can easily overclock it to
the advertised speeds so all of you guys
who are looking for a ram now you don't
have to change the timings and voltage
in order to get the advertised speed
this does have that benefit well guys
now that I've gone over the features of
this Ram let me answer that original
question is the RGB aspect of this ramp
for the extra $40 the answer is no
probably not it doesn't offer any
tangible value and it's really quite
unnecessary however if you guys really
want it
then you guys shouldn't just go ahead
and buy it as long as it would not make
you sacrifice any other PC parts to get
it this is also worth considering if
there is a great deal on it or when Ram
price it returns normal but in the
meantime I recommend that you guys
should just shave your money and buy a
cheaper rim and I'll get something else
in your PC for that money that you guys
save well guys that's all I have for
this video if you guys interested as to
what comes inside that box
make sure to click my link to the
unboxing of this ram in the description
below I hope you guys enjoyed this video
and helped you form an opinion about
this room as always if you guys liked
this video make sure to give it a like
if you guys loved it and would love to
see more videos just like this then make
sure to subscribe I would love to hear
thoughts about this ram Sam
should have post those in the comments
below that's all I have for you guys now
until next time bye